Ahzubillahimina Shaytana Rajim Bismillahur Rahman Rahim Alhamdulillahi Khalakal Wujoodi minal Adam Wa Ja'alin Noori mina Zulam Wa Mukhrijis Sabri minal Alam Wa Mulkit Tawbati Alan Nadam Fanashkuruhu Alal Masa'ibi Kamanashkuruhu Alan Ni'am Wa Nusalli Ala Rasool Hilakram Lis Sharafil Asham Wa Nuril Atam Wa Kitabil Mahkam Wa Kamalin Nabiyina Wa Khatam
Sayyidi waladi 'adam Alladi Basharabihi Aisabnu Maryam Waddaaliba Isatihi Ibrahimu Alaihis Salaam Heena Kaana Yarfa'u Kawa'idabaytillahil Muharram Fa sallallahu alaihi wa alaihi wa salam wa ala adba'aihi khairil umam Alladi barak Allahu bihim kaafatan nass ala'araba minhum wal ajam Wa sallallahu ala ameer almumineen alalzaalbateen Waqa'idil gurul Mahjaleen
Ghalib ala kulla ghalib matlooba kulla talib mahlana alibnabi talib Alhamdulillah aladi anzala ala abdihil kitab walam yaja'allahu aywajaa.
Walhamdulillah aladi lam yattakhizwaladan walam yakun lahu sharikun filmulk walam yakun lahuliyum minazulay wakabbirhu tadbirah.
Walhamdulillah aladi nahmaduhu wanastaainuhu wanastaghfiruhu wanukminu bihi wanatawakkalu alai
Wa na'udu bilahi min shuroori anfusina wa min sayyyati amalina man yahdihillahu falamudillala wa man yudlilhu falahadiyala Wa nashadwan laa ilaha illallah wahdahula sharikalah Wa nashadu anna Muhammadan Abdullahi wa rasulih Arsalahu Allahu ta'ala bilhuda wadin al-haq liyuz hirahu aladdini kulli wa kafabillahi sharida
Wa Nashadu Anna Mawlana Alibnabi Taalib wasiyhu wa waziru fasallahu alaihim wa ala alaihim wa salaymuhum tasliman kasiraan kasira Allahum mala 'ilmalana illa ma alamtana inna ka'antal alimulhakeem Allahumma alimna bima yanfa'ana wa yanfa'ana bima alamtana Allahumma inna na'uzu bikamin ail min la yanfaa wa min qalbin la yaksha wa min aainin la tadma wa min nafsin la tashfa
Fa'amma ba'adiyakunu subhana wa ta'ala fi kitabahi kareem pa'adanakula aadhubillahi mina shaytan arajeen bismillahu rahman ar-rahim Rabbish Rahli sadri wa yasir li amri wahluli okdatam millisani yafqa'uqawli Allahum masabitna aindal maltibila ilaha illa Allahu Allahummajalna minaladina amanum wa amir al-Salihad wa tawa saabil haq wa tawa saabr amin ya rabbil alameen once again assalam alaikum wa rahmatullahi wa barakatu.
So in the previous session we looked at the Quranic formula that allows us to gain some understanding about who our Creator is and you know what his intentions are.
That Quranic formula is declared in the verse
sanuri him ayatina fil aafaqi wafi anfusi him hatha ya tabaiya na lahum annahul haq So today I want to explore this verse a bit more in detail just to point out some interesting facts about it.
Allah says, We will show them our signs in the universe and in their own cells, in their own souls until it becomes absolutely clear to them that all of this is the ultimate truth or that it can also be understood as so that it becomes absolutely manifest to them that Allah is the ultimate truth.
So I explained that the signs and the horizons tell us about the nature and the capabilities of Allah and the signs in our soul, in our nafs, it tells us about the intentions of Allah because Allah created us all in His own image and therefore He only demands from Himself or He demands for Himself rather what we demand from others in terms of rights.
And this is how the analogy is between the Zahir and the Baatin, the horizon and the soul.
This is how it works, right?
So, between the comparison of the Zahir and Baatin, we find the insights into the inner workings of deen, of how religion works.
So, Rasulullah , he said in a hadith, Innallaha assa sadina hu ala mithaali khalqihi
that indeed Allah founded his religion on the pattern of creation to provide evidence for his religion through the world and then to provide evidence for the world through his religion right in other words he created the physical world on the exact same principles and patterns as the spiritual world and why did he do that
so that the human intellect could study the physical in the horizons and then be able to relate to those teachings with the spiritual realm.
So, horizon and the soul or the self are the keys to learning about Allah .
He dispersed, Allah dispersed the knowledge of who he is
in the horizons.
And a simple way to understand this concept is the example of light.
Right?
So if you look at light we know that light is...
it's white.
Right?
So if you look at this image they call it white light because it doesn't have any color.
But what happens when you pass that light through a prism?
We know that prism is just a medium.
It's a medium of glass, right?
And when this white light, it hits this glass, it refracts, right?
It bends.
And the result of that, a whole spectrum of colors show up from violet to red and everything in between.
In the same way when the light of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala hits creation, you know, because the Quran tells us that Allah is the light of the heavens and the earth, right?
He is the light of the heavens and the earth.
So what happens is that when this pure light of Allah's essence, when it hits creation, when it enters the realm of physicality, it refracts into the spectrum of these divine attributes.
You see?
This is why we get all these different manifestations of Allah's essence in this universe.
So this Alam, you know, you can look at it as a prism that is manifesting Allah's various attributes in creations for us to observe.
So, in one instance, we see that Allah is Kareem, right?
We see that He is generous.
So, in another instance, the universe shows us that Allah is Jabbar, He is the compeller.
In another instance, the aalam reveals to us that He is Qahar, the subduer.
In another instance, we see that He is Aziz, the powerful.
In another instance, we see that He is Muzil, the humiliator.
In another we see that he is Mawiz, the bestower of honor.
So the Aalam essentially serves as this colossal theater for the divine manifestations of these attributes of Allah.
And that is how we come to know about him.
Now why did he set the stage up in this way?
Because like I mentioned earlier, the human intellect
It learns by defining and limiting things.
Right?
Just as the body works by breaking down food.
So if you look at how the intellect works, it works just like the body.
In order to digest knowledge, it has to take in the whole, break it down into parts, and then understand each part individually.
Right?
Only then it can sum those parts up again to understand the whole.
So the Aalam it presents us these parts in the form of these divine attributes so that we can reflect on them individually and then sum them up to put together a more complete understanding of our Creator.
So this is the essential theme of Quran.
It invites us to reflect on the heavens and the earth, the horizons and the soul
Because through that very reflection, we can recognize our creator and his abilities.
And then once we've done that, it turns our attention inward onto the soul, the nafs, to understand the purpose of our creation.
Right?
So now what is the purpose of our creation?
Scholars say that there are three reasons for the creation of human beings and what's beautiful about this distinction is that it allows for purposeful existence for not just Muslims but for people of other beliefs as well or even people without belief.
So he says that the first reason for creation of human beings he says is Imara.
Right?
Cultivation.
Allah says, We brought you forth from the earth to cultivate it.
That's the first reason.
The second reason, He says, is ibada.
We only created the jinn which are beings of the unseen realm and humans which are beings of the seen realm for the purpose of ibada.
for willing worship.
So Ibn Abbas said in a narration that the purpose behind the creation of human beings was also li'arifun Allah to know Allah and to know Allah is to love Allah.
So those of you who have heard my session on those on that stages of love you know that Ubudiyya is one of the levels of muhabbah right?
is one of the higher levels of love.
Therefore he created the Jinn and the human beings to love him.
Right?
So...
...
it can also be taken as I did not create Jinn and man except to love me.
So those are the two reasons.
The third and the last reason for creation of human being he says is Khilafa.
We made you Khulafa because the Khalifa, the Caliph is the one who stands in place of somebody else right?
He is the one who is left behind.
He is left behind to stand in the place of someone else.
In other words, a Khalifa is a steward.
Allah created us as His stewards on this earth.
Why?
So that He can witness what we do with all the external and internal gifts that He blessed us with.
That's the test.
Now, there are two types of Khilafah.
There are two types of Khulafa.
We have been made a Caliph over ourselves and then over others.
So for the Khilafa of the Self, Allah says, He said to the angels, I have decided to create a Caliph in this earth.
And then in Surah Swad, He says,
He says, O Daud, we have made you a caliph in the earth.
So this is the second type of Khilafa that is mentioned in the Quran.
So there are two types of Khilafa.
The first is to rule yourself and the second is to rule others.
but the condition of ruling others is that you rule yourself first, that you take control and mastery of your nafs first and so here in this verse Tawud is being told we have put you in the earth to rule over others because he was made a ruler over Bani Israel, right?
So,
so that you can judge among them with the truth and then he says do not follow your own caprice do not follow your own whims in other words you have to rule yourself first before you can rule others you see because if you do not do that and the fa in the you see begins with fa the fa here is for causation
Because if you do not do that, if you do follow your caprice, if you do follow your whims, your appetites, then it will lead you astray from the path of Allah.
So what are we as caliphs of Allah and how are we doing as Allah's representatives on earth?
So, I'd like to spend a little time talking about this today because I think it's really important to put this into perspective.
How are we doing as Allah's representatives?
He says, We will show them our signs in the horizon and in our own souls.
Allah will let us know through the signs of what we see around us.
He will let us know the reality of our existence.
So let's look at some of the signs that we see in the horizons today.
Right?
Let's reflect on some of these signs to understand who we are and how we are doing as caliphs of Allah.
Just as a physician would look at the symptoms of a sick patient.
So Allah says in Surah Room
He says, Zahar al-fasadu fil barri wal bahari bima kasabad aydi an naas liyudhika hum wa adal ladi amilu la'allahum yarji'um He says, Zahar al-fasadu fil barri wal bahari bima kasabad aydi an naas Mischief, corruption, pollution has appeared on the land and sea because of what the hands of men have earned.
And again the lamb here is for causation.
So that Allah can give them a taste of their deeds in order for them to turn back to Him.
So we see that the reason Allah makes our negative actions have negative repercussions is in order for us to return back to Allah.
This is why negative actions have negative consequences so that, you know, it helps us return back to Allah.
Scholars say that Zahar al-Fasad is actually a nuqs filbahri walbahr.
So it means the diminished blessings of Allah on earth.
You lose the blessings of the earth.
And it also means Al-Qahat which is droughts and famines and you know all the other harm that comes in agriculture.
the fruit of the land you know the land stops growing crops it also means that the benefits of the oceans disappear from the fish and the other animals that live in the oceans you know like the whales and all of this is going to happen because of what we earn from our own sinfulness because human beings even though created in the best of forms in the very image of its creator you know with all
of his divine attributes, that human being is still capable of extreme corruption when he deviates from his divinity, when he deviates from his original state.
This is that very concern that the angels expressed when Allah mentioned the creation of Adam.
He said, This is what the angel said, right?
Are you seriously considering creating a species in this earth who will create facade and who will spill blood?
The word facade if you look at it in the English dictionary it means rottenness, spoilness, corruption, decay, decomposition, putrid, depravity, wickedness, viciousness, iniquity, immorality, weakness,
Perversion, wrongness, incorrectness, all of these are meanings embodied in the word facade.
If you look at the word pollution in the English dictionary, it says, undesirable state of the natural environment being contaminated with harmful substances as consequences of human activities.
You see, this is the result.
So even in our language, pollution is a dominant problem on the planet.
You know, we as human beings, we are responsible for the present state of the earth today.
Our conditions of hardships in the form of famines and extreme weathers and earthquakes and floods, these are nothing more than Bima Kathabat Aidi and nass from what our own hands have earned.
Many countries are in a major crisis because of fires that were started in forests, right?
Climate changes are driving up temperatures.
And as these temperatures rise, there are more incidents of fire.
Another aspect of this facade is the air itself.
In India, it has been estimated that half a million people die from air pollution, half a million people.
We had 15,000 people die from terrorism and the US government had moved heavens and earth to have this war on terrorism.
Yet half a million people suffer and die from air pollution just in India.
Where's the war against that?
Where's the war against noise pollution?
In Pakistan and India, look at the levels of noise pollution in the form of honking and yelling and screaming and the noise from rickshaws and taxis, you know, broken silencers.
That's all man-made facade.
Today we know that the world is rapidly moving towards desertification, right?
This is because what we're losing what they call topsoil.
Desertification is literally where a place that once had foliage it turns into desert and it has already happened in large portions of fertile land and this problem just continues to grow.
I was reading this book the other day in which it said that there was once a time when all of North Africa was so fertile
you know that before Banu Hilau, before they got into Africa, he wrote that a squirrel could run from Sinjab, from Egypt all the way to Morocco without its feet ever touching the ground.
Imagine that.
A squirrel could run from Egypt to Morocco without its feet ever touching the ground.
The land was so fertile but when these Banu Hilau, when they entered North Africa they were like locusts.
They devoured all the resources.
So, desertification is another example of ...
from what our own hands have earned.
Another aspect of Fasad, as Allah says, you know, in the Quran, The earth has been put out for the Anam.
The word Anam comes from naum, which means sleep.
So Anam are creatures that sleep.
So this verse is actually talking about all sentient beings.
It is not just about human beings.
So it includes the animal kingdom.
Allah says in the Quran, That there is no creature on the earth that walks the earth.
And there is no bird that flies with its two wings, except that they have communities like unto you.
Allah tells us that the animal kingdoms are communities just like us.
And then He says, That He did not leave anything out from this book.
Even the animals are acknowledged in the Quran.
We know that there are animals that mate for life.
We know that animals make huge pilgrimage and you know and vast migrations to places just like we do.
Right?
And today because of the sins of mankind, you know animals have all these problems.
I mean dogs are on Prozac.
In the United States, they put dogs on Prozac, which are antidepressants because they are depressed in the houses of depressed and miserable people.
Dogs are not naturally depressed animals, but there are so many houses in the US that are so sick that the dogs and the cats themselves get sick because they are sentient beings, they are emotional creatures.
They feel and experience emotions just like we do.
So there are all these examples of facade that we see in the horizons.
Look at the problem of endangered species caused by the hands of man.
There are like, I think there are 25 critically endangered species of the world that are from the most beautiful and the most majestic animals.
Think about that.
These are animals that the ancient Arabs used to name their children after.
Animals like, you know, lions and tigers, Asad and Fahad.
Right?
These are animals that the Arabs, they named their men after.
They used to name them after these Muftarisad, you know, after animals that attacked their prey.
that they would name the men after these muftarisat, these animals that attack the prey.
And then they would name their women after the prey itself, you know, like Maha and Ghazala.
You know, so Fahad goes after Maha and she doesn't stand a chance.
So that was the ancient Arab concept, right?
You know, that is why we have all these beautiful names in Arabic.
But what's interesting is that if you look at the species that are endangered today, they're not the cockroaches, they're not the rats, they're not the snakes, they're flourishing.
The animals and species that are endangered are the ones that
represent the divine qualities within us that are disappearing right the eagle the peregrine the lion the tiger the elephants these are the animals that represent those great qualities in human beings that are disappearing today within your own souls why don't you reflect
We've got plenty of cockroaches out there in human disguise.
We've got plenty of rats and snakes out there in human disguise, taking hold of the greatest offices in countries, becoming presidents and things like that.
But what we do not find is the courage of lions.
What we do not find today is the majesty of the eagles in human form.
These are qualities that are extinct from human beings today.
And I can go on and on and I'm sure you can think of and add so much more.
But this is what we're doing as caliphs and the stewards of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
We are destroying the very earth that sustains us and provides us with our livelihood.
And then we complain that we have problems.
You know why doesn't Allah solve all our problems?
Why should He?
He's not our janitor, He's not our servant, He's not our errand boy.
No, He created us in His image so that we could create Jannah on earth, just as He created Jannah on heaven.
Why else do you think Adam alaihis salam was created in Jannah?
Just for fun?
If He was created for the earth, I am planning to create
a caliph on Earth why why did he need to be created in Jannah when he was being created for Earth he could have been directly created in on the Earth right then why did Allah create him in Jannah he was created in Jannah so that he could see and experience the beauty of that place so that when he comes to the Earth
He could cultivate that land and create that same Jannah on earth.
That is the purpose of a caliph, of a Khalifa.
He brought you forth from the earth in order to cultivate it, in order to create the same Jannah on this earth.
And what did we do?
And why did this happen?
You know, how did things get so bad and so out of hand?
because of our corruption, because of our facade, our deviation from the divine attributes and the majestic qualities that Allah created us with.
And so this is why he created the Aalameen for us so that we can study the signs of the horizons, the heavens and the earth to learn the ideal conditions of the Nafs.
the ideal condition of the soul through his divine attributes.
But we as human beings, as Khalifatullah, we have failed miserably and we have proven that the angels did have valid grounds for their concerns.
That's what we have proved, that they clearly knew what they were talking about when they said, Do you really wish to create someone on this earth who will sow corruption and spill blood?
Obviously, they knew what they were talking about.
So what is it that we have deviated from?
We have deviated from the divine attributes.
We have deviated from the character of Allah.
The word for character in Arabic is Akhlaq, right?
And the word Akhlaq comes from the word Khulq.
Akhlaq is the plural, Khulq is the singular.
And this is really interesting because we are called Khalq, right?
The word Khalq means creation.
Sadaf, your mic is on.
Can you please turn it off?
No problem.
Right?
So hulk means character and hulk means creation, which is related to the body.
So hulk is related to the body.
and the body exists in the horizons and Khulk which means character it belongs to the soul, it belongs to the nafs and they're both made-up of the same letters and in the same sequence.
So according to the science of Arabic both these words are closely related in meaning.
The word Khalq is related to the body which is nourished by this physical world, the word Khulk
Character, it takes its nourishment from the spiritual world.
You see?
Khalq represents the existence of the body.
Khulq represents the existence of the soul.
And both these words, they begin with the letter Kha which is a sound of friction in Arabic, right?
Kha and friction takes effort.
So Kha in Arabic is a sound of effort.
This is because the body takes effort to develop and so does character.
Character takes a lot of effort to develop.
Therefore, if Khalq is the essence of the body then Khulq or character is the essence of the soul.
When we die, the body returns back into the earth with whatever it has acquired from the physical world
and the soul returns back to the spiritual world with its nourishment of character that it has developed in this world.
That's our true earning.
That's our character is our true accomplishment.
That's our real acquisition.
Khulk character.
A soul that returns back to its master without a developed Khulk is an impoverished soul.
It is the soul that has failed to
fulfill its purpose of khilpa it has failed the purpose of its creation and that's why a weak soul cannot enter Jannah because when the body is weak it cannot benefit from the offerings of this physical world right?
I mean we know that this world has a lot to offer in terms of temporal pleasures but if you're extremely weak if you can't even get off your bed you're not going to be able to enjoy those pleasures right?
In the same way a soul that is empty, that is bankrupt of Akhlaq is not going to be able to benefit from the pleasures of the afterlife.
It's as simple as that.
Now how is character developed?
It is developed through revelation.
As I said Quran is an
You know if you look at it in an oversimplified statement, Quran is the explanation of divine attributes of Allah.
It explains the attributes of Allah and why he has those attributes.
Right?
He is Azim because he created this massive universe.
The size of this universe tells us that he's Azim.
He is Qawi.
He's all-powerful.
Because not only did He create this massive universe, He created it with a single command qun be and fayakun it was.
So in essence, Quran is just the description of Allah's attributes explaining why He is al-ilah.
He created all of us as ilah but then gave us through the aalam, He gave us these signs for us to recognize that He is the al-ilah, He is Allah.
Our hearts witness these divine attributes in the light of revelation which then creates belief, iman.
The more the heart understands revelation the more we grow in our belief which then nourishes and develops our character.
And so character is nothing more than absorbing these divine attributes into the heart from revelation and then reflecting those same divine attributes into the rest of Allah's creation.
That is what character is.
It is internalizing, developing, and training the heart in the light of these divine attributes.
And then reflecting them in our interactions with Allah's creation.
That is Aflaq.
And that is Islam.
Islam is all about interactions.
It is all about Muhammad.
Now, there are three types of interactions in Islam.
There is the interaction with Allah , the rights of Allah.
There is interacting with the self which is or the right of the soul.
And then interaction with the creations of Allah which is , the rights of others, the right of other slaves.
So, I'll just quickly talk about each of these so that you see how these are all related to the attributes of Allah.
So, the first is the right of Allah.
Right?
What right does Allah have over us?
That we recognize His attributes in the heavens and the earth and we approach Him with love for everything that He has done for us.
And then out of that love we willingly obey and serve Him as faithful slaves which is Rubudiya.
So, it is the right of the Rabb that we become Aabd.
That we worship Him recognizing the fact that only He deserves to be worshipped.
That is the right of the Creator over His creation.
Right?
Now, what is the right of the self?
The right of the self is to reflect on the attributes of Allah in the Aalam through the teachings of Quran, to learn
those attributes, those qualities, basically to learn the character of our master and to then internalize and harvest those qualities within our own hearts to develop our own character, our own Akhlaq.
Because we have been created in imamate of our master.
We have been created to represent our master on this earth which means we have to adopt the qualities and characteristics of our master.
Right?
That is what a Khalifa is, a representative.
You can't represent unless you become like the one you are representing.
Right?
So, the second step of Haqqun Nafs is that you train it in the attributes of Allah, in the character of Allah.
So, for instance, Allah is qareem.
He is generous.
Therefore, it is the right of my soul that I train it to be generous.
Generous with who?
Generous with myself.
What is the greatest generosity that I can show myself?
To try to protect it from sins and put it to work in good deeds.
That is the greatest generosity for my soul.
We know that Allah is al-haqq He is truthful.
So it is the right of my soul that I train it to be truthful.
With who?
With myself.
What is the greatest falsehood that the nafs is trapped in?
The greatest lie that the nafs is trapped in is the delusion of this reality of dunya.
So I must train myself on a daily basis to try to wake up from my delusions about this world.
Right?
I need to wake up to the reality that I'm only here for a short period of time.
Everything that I'm working for in the worldly sense will be left behind.
I will be left with nothing other than this title of Mayyat.
You know, my loved ones, the people that I am slaving for day and night, they will be the first to dump me in a grave and throw dirt in my face.
So I better not sacrifice my afterlife for this temporary life, you know, by eating haram, by
So that's being truthful to the self.
So the right of the self is that I internalize the attributes of Allah and train myself in those attributes in order to develop my character so that I can realize the potential that I was created with.
I was created in imamate of God to act like God and God is nothing other than just.
This is why one of the divine names of Allah is Al-Mu'min, which essentially means, you know, the giver of tranquility, the one who brings peace.
You know, Mu'min comes from the word Aman, which means peace.
So that is the right of my nafs that I train it in the attributes of Allah.
And finally, there is the right of others.
Now what are the right of others?
So right of Allah was recognizing His divine attributes in creation and submitting to Him willingly out of love in the form of ibada.
Right?
Right of the self was to internalize those divine attributes.
I've already recognized them.
The next step is to internalize those divine attributes to build my own character, to align it with the character of Allah, to become like the creator.
Once that character has developed, only then the final rite of Qaqooq al Ibaat comes into play, which is the idea of now reflecting those divine attributes of Allah in interactions with creation.
We trained ourselves to become generous with our own self.
Now it's time to reflect that generosity onto others in our dealings with them.
We trained ourselves to be truthful and sincere with our own nafs.
Now it's time to reflect that truthfulness, that sidq, that sincerity in our dealings with others.
We've recognized how Allah is forgiving with us, how He's patient with us.
We now have to reflect those attributes by being patient and forgiving with others.
And that is not an easy task.
this is why one has to go through the training of fulfilling the previous two rights before he can fulfill this third right and our problem today is that everyone is a preacher you know nobody takes the time to fix themselves but they are when it comes to preaching everybody is a teacher everybody is enforcing things on others I mean I'm not an enforcer I just share knowledge
So there's a difference between teaching and between enforcing.
But today, you know, everybody's the first, oh, you're doing that wrong, you should be doing that, that, you know, you're going to hell.
That's pretty much, you know, you can't even put a shirt on today without getting some criticism from someone.
Cannot even mop the floor without somebody telling you, oh, you have to go clockwise and not anti-clockwise, I mean, right?
But people never take the time to actually develop their own character, the person saying that
usually doesn't have the most perfect character.
That person is full of flaws himself, but they are enjoying, but they, you know, force that knowledge on others.
And that is why it's not working.
That is why we have this really big problem in Islam today within our community, within the Suleimani Jamaat, outside of the Suleimani Jamaat where children are developing this hatred for the religion because it's, you know, their first thing is
You don't pray five times a day.
Why you keep forcing that prayer on me?
So we first have to develop our own self and that's why this is so...
because even dealing with people is not easy.
You know, a man once came to the Messenger of Allah and he said, O Messenger of Allah, I give him.
but he withholds from me.
I come to him but he cuts me off.
What should I do?
The Prophet said, That is Salatul Rahim.
What you're doing is the right thing.
Continue meeting him even though he is cutting you off.
That is Islam and that's hard work.
I mean don't think this is an easy religion.
There are many easy religions in this world.
Islam is not one of them.
Islam demands hard work.
it is not easy to become godlike but then we want to be people that strive right we want to be people that honor ourselves that we don't just take a handout from even from Allah we want to earn our rewards because Allah created us as honored creatures right we have ennobled the children of Adam
We made you leaders over the land and the oceans.
We gave you a heart.
We gave you an intellect.
We nourished it through our revelation.
We gave you the ability to overcome the worst aspects of yourself.
And even if you capitulate from time to time, we've given you the means to renew and restore your soul through Tawbah, through repentance.
What a gift from Allah.
So this is what we have to do.
And we have to do it with Ikhlas, with sincerity.
Only for the sake of Allah.
But that's not going to be easy.
So these are the three dimensions of Allah.
The right of Allah, the right of the self, and the right of others.
Recognizing the attributes of Allah in the heavens and the earth help us understand the rights of Allah.
Internalizing those divine attributes to develop our character is the right of the soul.
It's .
Reflecting those divine attributes onto creation of Allah is the right of others.
It is the right...
and because this last one is the most challenging of all it cannot be accomplished unless and until the soul has first been illuminated with the character of Allah.
This is why RasulAllah said, Adopt the character and the qualities of Allah.
You know there's a narration in which RasulAllah once saw a man talking to Mawlana Ali in a very disrespectful manner, right?
And in return Mawlana Ali responded back to this guy with complete kindness, complete humility.
But despite his kindness, this man continued to act in a disrespectful manner with him.
But Maulana Ali kept responding with kindness over and over and over again.
And then finally when the man left, the Prophet asked him, Ya Ali, I saw this man talk to you in such a disrespectful manner.
You know, he treated you in such a horrible way over and over again and yet you kept showing him kindness and respect in return.
Why is that?
And Maulana Ali said, Ya Rasulullah,
If this man is not willing to give up his wretched and evil nature to interact with me, why should I give up my good character to interact with him?
Subhanallah, what a beautiful statement.
If this man is not willing to give up his wretched and evil nature in his interaction with me, then why should I give up my good character in my interaction with him?
In other words, if this man continues to hold on to something ugly, why should I let go of something beautiful that I possess?
That's the beauty of Akhlaq.
And this is why we follow the example of Rasulullah who according to the Quran reached the pinnacle of Akhlaq.
through his character and nothing other than his character, he purified the most barbaric and the most vile group of people that ever walked this earth.
I mean read the history of Islam.
You know understand the mentality of these people he was sent to Rifaam.
Just think if you were sent to these people, just put yourself in his shoes.
These were the worst, they were worse than animals.
There was not a single virtue that existed in them.
They were insane.
They would eat the flesh of elephants and crocodiles.
When they ate a goat, they would even boil and eat its leather.
They would burn their enemies alive in a bonfire.
They would rip out their skin and wear it like a scarf while they were alive, the enemy.
They would crack open their skull and use it as a cup to drink wine in.
Their women would dye their clothes in the blood of their enemies and wear it.
They were so barbaric that they would not just kill their enemy, they would tie that enemy's camel to his grave and starve it to death.
That's how barbaric these people were.
Sons would marry their mothers.
Fathers married their daughters.
Daughters were buried alive.
They used the children of their enemy for target practice.
Even their prayers were barbaric.
Can you imagine that?
The prayers were horrific.
Ya rabbi falataja al-hayati muzillatu wala mawtati bainan nisa'in nawa'ihi walaa kin qateelan tamzaquttairi hawlahu wa tashrubu girbanu dammi min jawaarihi O Lord, do not disgrace me in my life by letting me die on a bed between grieving women.
Give me a death where birds are tearing out my flesh and crows are drinking the fresh blood gushing out of my limbs.
I mean, this was their prayers.
This was the state of the Arabs when Rasulullah was sent between them.
Can you imagine that?
This was the group he was sent to reform.
And look what he did.
Subhanallah.
He converted these people into Rahmatullah Alaihi.
Today we don't even mention their names without saying Rahmatullah Alaihi after it.
May Allah have mercy on them.
That is the kind of character he
He cultivated within them.
And this is by their own admission, the admission of these own Jahili Arabs on the day of Qadir when Rasulullah asked Am I not more beloved to you than your own souls?
What did they say?
Indeed you are a Prophet of Allah.
We were animals.
You turned us into human beings.
And how did he do that?
Through his impeccable Akhlaq.
By internalizing the divine attributes of his creator, by absorbing them to develop this immaculate character
and then finally reflecting those very same attributes into creation with such intensity that the Creator Himself had to acknowledge in the Quran .
Indeed, no doubt about it, you have achieved the utmost and the most exalted level of character.
SubhanAllah.
May Allah grant us a few rays
from the light of that sun that shined in the form of Rasulullah .
And may Allah, you know, give us the tawfiq to act in some fashion as his khalifa, as his representatives.
And the only way that can happen is through this training of adopting the characteristics of Allah.
Alhamdulillahi Rabbil Alameen Wassalatu Wassalamu Ala Rasuli Saida Muhammadan Khatimin Nabin Wassalin Waalahi Waasi Alibnabi Talib Al Fateha